foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here joined by John
how are you I'm I'm in a days we just
got out of watching black panther
wakanda forever leave a like don't
forget to do that now we're shooting
this in Burbank we got our friend Aaron
holding the camera burbank's really
serious about [ __ ] around here at any
moment we could be tackled by security I
know what are you doing here stop
filming pay us for this time now in case
you don't know anything about this film
there's gonna be no spoilers here and
this movie takes place after the passive
t'challa Chadwick Boseman as you see in
the trailers there's people who are
seeing this as a moment of vulnerability
for wakanda they're trying to take
vibranium this movie's two hours and 40
something minutes there's a lot of plot
even involving why Neymar and them are
fighting that is just not revealed in
the trailers I know some people don't
care if they talk about it but because
the marketing he didn't put it out there
I don't want to put it out there but
know this the movie's like a really long
film and I thought every second every
minute of it was so Justified I loved
this movie so much when I saw the
trailers I kept saying it feels like
it's going to be so much about grief and
having to work together through grief
simultaneously be badass I found myself
like crying for a variety of different
reasons from beginning to end feeling
hopeful feeling just so shattered my
brain feels foggy from all the crying at
this very moment it is
the most powerful MCU movie I have seen
the easily the most emotional it felt
like such a necessary experience for
everyone involved with this movie feels
so purposeful it's like an epic drama is
how I would describe it you know before
we go into like Namor Sheree Angela
Bassett my God ramonda yeah
John what'd you think no I I'm similarly
dazed because it is such a cathartic
experience and because it does
intermingle so much with actual life
yeah there are crazy high concept things
happening on screen and yet it still
feels completely personal the entire
time and every action feels motivated by
the grief and vulnerability that
everybody on screen is feeling for
different reasons and you know coming
out of the previous movie it still
maintains all of that geopolitical
Intrigue because obviously in the place
we rejoin wakanda they are in a globally
vulnerable state not just an emotionally
vulnerable state but you get this
interesting mixture where so much of the
action literally even the fighting that
happens on screen does feel like it is
coming from the same place as a lot of
the dramatic scenes it is you know the
most powerful and the most meaningful
and the most impactful MCU movie
probably in rousing as hell it is yeah
yeah yeah but not in the way of like how
an end game is rousing yeah it's not on
your left yeah but it is like it has a
life of firming quality just as much as
it is about grieving the loss of
somebody and there are some really
beautiful cultural motifs that they use
to drive that home that really sing
beyond all the other stuff that you're
expecting that is there too like it's
still thrilling and it's still fun and
it's still endearing in ways but yeah
there is a Paul that they don't turn
away from that is cast over the entire
proceedings and even characters who
aren't going through what the wakandans
are going through have similarly vital
motivations and griefs of their own to
rectify between everyone in wakanda to
everyone in telecon and in between
there's so much life and culture and
Beauty on display that it's weird so
many people I think would want to
imagine this movie any other way if it
meant Chadwick could be here and I
certainly would probably trade for that
reality but at the same time the on the
timeline we live on this does feel like
a unique snapshot of a moment that also
gets to be all the MCU stuff you want it
to be too and I think that's really
special there are some really just
powerful performances in here it's the
the best I think out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I'll be honest like I
was well I was looking forward to shuri
but I wasn't exactly walking into this
film going can't wait to see what
Leticia Wright does for some reason I
just wasn't in that mindset what I
noticed was that there are times where
when she had scenes where she was like
displaying Joy or happiness I would
start to tear up or cry because her
portrayal here carries this this ever
growing pain throughout the entire film
that's coming out in all kinds of ways
of aggression and anger and drive it
would just break my heart whenever I
would see her happy you know it's it's
that kind of it's just it's getting me
right now it would just mess me up
because you could see how palpable and
how much it just resonates throughout
the entire film because that's what this
film's so much about is everyone's
struggling emotional only right now and
we're just trying to keep moving and
everyone's threatening us and the only
way we can stay together through such a
tumultuous time is by Banning together
so that phrase like calling this wakanda
forever I felt that way more than the
first black panther way more than
whatever it's been said I felt that like
yeah wakanda forever you just feel that
phrase that Mantra but it's such a
personal fill like it's so personal it's
two hours and 40 minutes for a reason it
is a slow-moving film that will have
action scenes that are just so intense
like this is Cinema all right this is
James Cameron Cameron
this is a great film there are these
action scenes in here where the
intensity it's suspenseful it's engaging
and you're watching characters even on
the side of Neymar they're not Atlantis
yeah they call them a different thing I
forget how you adapt telecon into its
people's name but yeah even with them
it's everyone's just trying to do their
best and they they have these core
themes about family and about vengeance
and about how to cope and it's just like
that in this giant massive expensive ass
film at the same time Namor
he was so threatening and he's easily
one of the best Marvel villains I was
halfway through watching him monologue
at one scene and then I got pulled out
for a split second going holy [ __ ]
this guy's incredible I know because I
haven't even thought about like how
great he's doing because he's so he just
feels like this character yeah he's just
he just is this person you get entirely
where he's coming from the flying the
action scenes with him are awesome and
as much as you get where he's coming
from he also pisses you off so much at
times yeah it's a really great dichotomy
they draw because he is completely
understandable and yet he is your
antagonist for various reasons and it's
really effectively done it does not
succumb to these stereotype of like oh
you're just kind of going up against
yourself like it definitely avoids that
and it gives you somebody with a clear
motive a clear purpose that you can
again continuing that line from what we
got with killmonger it's like you you
understand where this guy's coming from
but more so even than killmonger I would
argue Angela Bassett I believe deserves
an Oscar nomination for this I don't
think I've said that about an MCU
performance the strength and Poise and
the amount of command she has on the
screen green you've seen Angela Bassett
do an intense performance but there is
so much more percolating underneath it
yeah like I would absolutely agree I'm
like please nominate her like I notice
you keep saying pain doesn't sound like
a fun movie but it's like a necessary
pain it's like you're grieving through
with these characters you're doing all
this necessary World building and you're
exploring talocon like there's so much
I'm like wow the trailers didn't show
you so much there's so much Beauty on
display deny Guerrera as a koye
just
you know like man you miss you missed
the Charlie you missed Chadwick with
Ryan coogler and company gave with their
performers here this is the performance
of them that I'm going to remember every
one of them first black panther I'm like
I really like them but of course
Chadwick and Michael B Jordan those are
the ones you think of it's a true
Ensemble peace masterful performances
and yeah it is I'm sorry for talking so
much and Baku Winston Duke total blast
to kick it with seen stealer Riri
Williams was the quality of this film I
was concerned about this film obviously
is looked at as something so personal I
felt are we gonna get distracted by them
trying to set up Iron Man she's a very
important character in this film and she
fits yeah perfectly yeah it is not just
hey look how far ironhearted
it is not that she felt like such a real
person this friendship that she forms
with shuri by the time you know the
movie was ending I was like oh no I want
to still see them hang out I don't wanna
I wanna still see them together and it
makes you hope that shuri will appear
somewhere in Iron Heart to just continue
that Rapport they have everything to me
comes back to Leticia Wright for this
film whatever personal opinions you have
about Leticia right everything comes
back to me about like it circles around
her she was perfect absolutely
mesmerizing oh my God yes no yeah like
revelatory and and the way especially
she is used in the movie without saying
much is interesting and does come with
very much catharsis and a lot of its own
tough emotion that is unique it's like
you have everyone sharing you know a
certain amount of grief obviously but I
feel like at the center of the story you
have shuri but you also have Nakia in a
way that you know isn't really a part of
what people are talking about or what's
being pitched to you but she is one of
the brightest parts of the movie I feel
like when you see the trailer you know
what you're hearing a lot about is
they've lost their leader and now it
falls on the remaining people in wakanda
to carry on the Legacy and to take a
stand and and show their strengths still
so what they did with this film was they
went okay let's not try to find a new
lead let's instead really hone in on our
supporting players from the last movie
and make them the leads as tragic as it
is as beautiful as a tribute as this
film is like you feel Chadwick boseman's
missing presence and presence throughout
you feel his spirit imbued in everything
like when you say the missing presence
it's not like the movie's not good
because this would have been good yeah
that's something we're saying you feel
the longing that weight of the loss of
someone but weirdly I felt like they
came out with a film that was better
than the first one personally for me I
feel like this is a better film The
action's really great and imaginative
and dazzling yeah this is like the
wakanda version of the winter soldier
action in some ways you know a little
bit of that Aquaman wonder I think they
made the underwater stuff look better
than Aquaman it felt real more real
versus not trying to make this like a
Marvel vs DC comparison it just felt
actually real the music by all oh this
is some of the absolute this is
absolutely a cinematic score yeah it
feels spiritual throughout and it takes
those motifs from the previous movie but
it builds on them in really wonderful
ways it uses vocalizations and two it
crosses cultural boundaries because you
are dealing with ancient uh I think they
they name check my commands yeah it's
like you know you have so much hang in
there
beyond the the music of wakanda that
just makes it feel so much more rich and
alive and all the flourishes like you
can really feel the elegant quality of
the tones that they pull the sound
design is amazing the makeup and effects
are awesome my only real problem with
the film is that at times and it's not
like oh Marvel phase four it all the
just the crap you crap on with the
marble face force CGI it is like there
are times in the especially in the
finale where you're like you had some
very noticeable CGI but when I was
thinking that I was going Owen what
movie doesn't with a hat that relies on
CGI some shots will inevitably be a bit
better than others nobody has all the
time they need it even the greatest
technological looking movie of at the
time it comes out you will have moments
that go man that looks fake like some
other minor qualms I might have with the
movie because yeah I do think it does a
fantastic job World building and
handling this Ensemble because it is
very well written the entire thing is
motivated within characters it's a big
film but it's also extremely character
driven but at times the editing can feel
a tad off Pace but out of two hours and
40 minutes that thought maybe crossed my
mind at a very small handful of times
and there there's the humor works and
there's only one scene of humor that
felt like typical quote-unquote Marvel
comedy but the rest of the scenes that
make you laugh they don't feel that way
I thought this was a damn near perfect
experience and exactly what I thought it
should be more than what I wanted it to
be or expected it to be I thought it was
great there's a heavy hole throughout
but also inspiring and hopeful did you
just take different directions with
characters you just wouldn't expect and
yes perhaps the best post-credits scene
because it's a legit
powerful scene and not just like hey
what's coming next yeah yeah it's it's
very very spiritually in line with the
movie it makes sense to separate it and
make it the coda and I think it's a
really elegant use yeah it feels like
the real ending yeah yeah absolutely I
think it was a really elegant choice to
do it that way like it could have ended
where it ended but the post-credit feels
like no this is the real ending and it
does seem like the kind of movie that
will give you more on repeat viewings
for sure I want to watch it a couple
more times but could be my favorite of
the it's just above throw 11th
it could be my favorite uh I I don't
know yet I have to watch it again what'd
you guys think subscribe leave a like
click that Bell um yeah wakanda forever
this was this is one experience I'm
never gonna forget no never never it was
awesome this is truly unique
[Music]